y hacer reducciones personalmente
personales
[Música]
libre de las interferencias de la
política
reafirmaba principios básicos de
igualdad de que las mujeres pudieran
controlar su destino
y reforzaba un derecho fundamental de
primera privacidad de que todos podamos
decidir cómo vivir nuestras vidas ahora
siga esta ley debemos ser muy claros
la salud de las mujeres y su vida están
ahora en riesgo y
he estudiado este caso con mucho cuidado
he visto muchas confirmaciones del
tribunal supremo
cuando este caso siempre era discutido
yo creo realmente que era una decisión
correcta row versos way
para aplicar los las ley los derechos
fundamentales de la privacidad y de la
autonomía personal
era una decisión en un tema complejo un
equilibrio complejo entre el derecho a
elegir de las mujeres
y el derecho de los estados a regular
sobre el aborto una decisión que había
logrado un consenso nacional
muchos americanos de diversas religiones
encontraban correcto
y era un consenso que habían conseguido
jueces decididos tanto por los
demócratas como por los republicanos
en las cinco décadas que siguió la
decisión de wait
eisenhower reagan nixon georges double
you vox
todos esos jueces decididos por esos
presidentes
respaldaban roben huevos
ahora han sido tres jueces nombrados por
un presidente donalson
que han decidido eliminar un derecho
fundamental para las mujeres en este
país
no se equivoquen
esta decisión es una combinación entre
un esfuerzo deliberado durante décadas
para desequilibrar nuestras leyes
se convierte en realidad una ideología
extremo la corte ha hecho lo que nunca
antes había hecho
sacar un derecho que estaba consensuado
y que era totalmente fundamental para
tantos estadounidenses y que ya había
sido reconocido la decisión del tribunal
tiene directas inmediatas consecuencias
las leyes estatales que prohíben el
aborto hoy mismo van a tener efecto
arriesgando la salud de miles de mujeres
es extremo que las mujeres puedan a ser
castigadas para proteger su salud y que
deban tener que cargar con el hijo de
sus violadores
simplemente me deja atónito
los doctores serán criminalizados por
hacer su deber de cuidar
imagen imaginen tener mujeres jóvenes
teniendo que de tener hijos consecuencia
del incesto sin ninguna opción
que es demasiadas veces el caso
es cruel
y el tribunal
y
restituyó leyes estatales que van
decenas y siglos atrás
literalmente el tribunal llevó a eeuu
150 años atrás es un día triste para el
país desde mi perspectiva pero no
significa que la lucha ha terminado
déjenme ser muy claro y sin ambigüedades
la única manera que podemos asegurar el
derecho a elegir de las mujeres
es para que el congreso vuelva a
restituir estas protecciones estas
protecciones como un leyes federales
los votantes necesitan
que sus voces sean escuchadas en el
congreso
este otoño tenemos que elegir más
senadores y representantes
que defiendan el derecho a decidir en
las leyes federales más líderes
estatales que protejan este derecho al
nivel local
tenemos que tenemos que restablecer
estas protecciones de rouen wait
este otoño row está en las bromas las
libertades personales están en las urnas
el derecho a la privacidad la libertad
la igualdad están todas en las urnas
hasta entonces haré todo lo que esté en
mi poder para proteger los derechos de
las mujeres en los estados donde
enfrentarán las consecuencias de las
decisiones de hoy
muchos estados en este país todavía
reconocen los derechos de elegir de una
mujer a pesar de la decisión de la corte
de hoy
así que si una mujer que vive en un
estado donde se restringen los abortos
en la decisión del tribunal supremo no
le impide que viaje a otro estado donde
pueda abortar y no le impide a un doctor
en esos estados tratarlas
como el fiscal general ha hecho claro
las mujeres deben poder viajar de manera
segura a otros estados para buscar el
cuidado que necesitan
y mi administración defenderá ese
derecho
si algún representante intentan intentar
evitar ese derecho de viajar haré todo
lo que esté en mi poder
para combatir ese ataque contra
americano
el derecho a los anticonceptivos es
esencial también para el sistema de
salud
tenemos anticonceptivos que la dea han
aprobado hace 20 años
y que también están usados para tratar
embarazos que no terminan bien
gobernadores extremistas están
intentando bloquear los correos o el
acceso a medicinas o intentando
perseguir
datos de las mujeres en leyes que son
totalmente insensibles para la mayoría
de los estadounidenses
la asociación estadounidense médica
la asociación estadounidense de
ginecólogos me escribieron para decir
que estas leyes no están basadas en
ninguna evidencia científica
nos dicen que limitando el acceso a este
tipo de medicamentos la mortalidad
materna podría crecer en eeuu eso es lo
que ellos dicen
hoy le diré al departamento de salud que
tome pasos para asegurar de que todas
estas medicinas estarán disponibles en
su máxima y en su máxima capacidad
y los políticos no pueden interferir en
estas decisiones que se toman entre una
mujer
doctor de administración a seguirá
siendo vigilando vigilante mientras
todas estas decisiones se toman y
mientras tomamos todos estos pasos
protegeremos el derecho a la privacidad
de todo el mundo y esto es porque la ley
roe versus wade reconocía el derecho
fundamental a la privacidad
que ha servido como base a tantos otros
derechos que hemos terminado
dando por hecho
el derecho a tomar las mejores
decisiones para nuestra salud
el derecho para usar
anticonceptivos incluso para parejas
casadas en sus dormitorios
los dere el derecho para casarte con la
persona que quieres
esto es un camino totalmente peligroso
que está empezando a tomar el tribunal
vamos a terminar con dos puntos primero
pido a todo el mundo no importa cuánto
le importe esta decisión que todas las
protestas sean pacíficas pacíficas que
no haya intimidación la violencia nunca
es aceptable las amenazas la
intimidación
no son los mismos no son hablar no son
diálogo tenemos que luchar contra
cualquier tipo de violencia segundo
y
sé que muchos estamos desilusionados y
frustrantes que el tribunal esté sacando
de nosotros que se nos esté llevando un
derecho tan fundamental
escucha a todas las mujeres que se
sienten así en este momento las apoyo
las consecuencias y el consenso del
pueblo estadounidense
los principios de igualdad libertad
dignidad
y estabilidad de la ley
dice que robert sus web no debe ser
derogada
con esta decisión la mayoría
conservadora del tribunal muestra como
extremos son y como nos hemos alejado de
la mayoría de esta población
pero esta decisión no
puede ser la última palabra
[Música]
mi administración usará todos sus
poderes dentro de la ley pero también el
congreso debe actuar y con vuestro voto
vosotros podéis actuar
podéis tener la palabra final
esto no ha terminado
muchas gracias seguiremos hablando en
las próximas semanas
[Música]